[Music]
you died
what yeah last night or this morning
rather he passed away to sleep oh no you
know I don't know much about him but I
do remember uncle Steve loved Steve
Harvey I mean who doesn't
I miss America girl Sophie rose on
Monday yeah be there don't flake Quinta
Monday it's Friday
what I haven't even begun to grieve yet
my first gt-r hasn't [ __ ] yeah so
they're Muslim so it happens really
quick and I'm gonna need you to be there
and I don't even know that side of the
family aren't they like vegetarian or
something what am I supposed to do with
that I don't know them either and I love
pork but I'm still gonna be there so you
should be there June
[Music]
the circus to our so Steve was a good
man
it was a man of his word
when I first came here Steve was the
first person I met
we had a golf game Thank You Quinta
you're looking just like your mother
you're always so sweet thank you so
this lady is next to me is you like a
second cousin or something we're now
would like to invite Linda Steve
step-cousin
to come up and say a few words that's
all right
let's have the nearest family member
come up and say a few words that would
be you Quinta come on you went to
college
this should be good yeah your uncle
stayed was so proud Thanks
we're all here today because we loved
uncle Steve right whether we knew him
that well or not but not like me because
I know I'm very well because I'm his
family so I know I'm probably better
than anyone in the room great uncle
Steve love Steve Harvey so it's safe to
say he also loved Family Feud right who
here likes Family Feud right right how
about in great uncle Steve's honor we
all get up and play a rousing game of
family food right now right let's all
stand up and we're gonna have teams so
choose actually 15 minutes of this space
so due to some location issues we will
not be able to play family feel very
sorry about that
but tonight let's all watch family feud
and and when we watch let's think of
uncle Steve because after all it's what
he would have wanted all of us together
watching family feud rooting against the
white family together okay
let me give it a try happenin swingin
okay but only a little bit that's really
high wanna see me go a little bit higher
yeah I know I'm pretty good right yeah
we go I'm Peppa Pig they call what
you're doing getting cocky wanna see me
go a little bit higher what a swing
expert that's what
nice setup
you got a guardian kid some adult you're
here with yeah she's my guardian oh what
a shame all right after the truck bed
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
your hair looks nice Thanks I did it
myself yeah you didn't have time to get
it done I could I just decided not to
mm-hmm have you seen your cousin just
got her college degree oh good for her
yes when are you getting yours I don't
know maybe when she gets a six-figure
job like mine maybe in 20 years with her
degree in social reasoning studies
whatever that means well at least her
mom would can see her walk across the
stage hope her mother can remember that
pride when she realized some rise gang
mariah isn't gay she isn't out oh you
would know all about gay wouldn't you is
there something you're trying to tell me
Quinta are you sure are projecting on
Mariah and you do have a lot of gay
friends oh if I were gay you would know
it okay you want to know how Matt gay I
am because it can get real Sex in the
City in here real fast
oh this show is just crass like that is
Quinta how's everyone doing everyone is
good your nephew he just started high
school oh good for him I just wish he
had a role model that could tell him he
could go to college and graduate Oh God
again with the college thing mom he's
gonna be an engineer he doesn't have a
choice he has to go to college this is
true unless he drops out I'll a Steve
Jobs Kanye West a Mark Zuckerberg that's
enough I'm just saying well I have to
get going because I'm cooking dinner for
the family and we're having baked
chicken baked macaroni cornbread and
collard greens what are you having
[Music]
I'll be having a banana with some salt
packets
oh that sounds delicious
all right well mom you know what enjoy
your night
have fun so the family I say hello when
I get going I will all right what time
yeah I love you I love you too mom
I took a warm-up that banana
[Music]